[Music]  welcome to the waves and to your very  own foreteller here you can unlock  challenges and by the battle paths to  recruit this unsinkable crew of drifters  this little star way is kit  oh they grow up so fast I invited  Aquaman  he said yes so I said can you wear a  shirt he said dad then there's Jules  master engineer with her incredible  creations explore the four Atilla to  meet everyone in Elle crew plus check  out the Builder Brahma with the bezel  pass you can design your own by the end  of the season there will be uniquely  yours throughout your adventure  there will be new areas to explore new  ways to get around and hot new surprises  watch out so by the battle pass and  unlock your team of drifters start  designing your custom Brella earn 1500  feedbacks and more so what are you  waiting for night dive n  you